foreign
[Music]
concerns farming Farms are where we get
our food our metaphors about fascism and
they are even the subject of
surprisingly popular video games like
this I've played Farming Simulator a
whole new world was revealed to me
agriculture
animal husbandry Forestry
and a lot of exciting Machinery never
cultivated a field before and
oh boy let me tell you about spraying a
field with the double application rate
and dynamic working with that's
something else believe me farming is
easy mastering it is a challenge and
there's always time to relax
you know and great news for that guy
who's never cultivated a field before
you still haven't you haven't grown a
vegetable you haven't sprayed anything
with a double rate of anything and you
haven't even really watched any Barnyard
animals go to pound town that game is
too farming what Call of Duty is to war
it looks similar but if you were ever
caught upon to do the real thing you
would be categorically now that
farmer looks pretty much like the
stereotypical one in most people's minds
a white guy in overalls on a tractor
it's a Trope drawn straight from
children's picture books where Farmers
always seem to be a white man with some
straw in his mouth who's holding an
adorable little piglet that while the
book skips over it he does eventually
kill and eat but while some farmers do
indeed look like that many of the people
doing some of the hardest work on farms
hired farmed laborers do not there are
roughly one and a half million hired
Farm Workers in the U.S mostly crop
workers and government estimates
indicate that most of those are foreign
born and among them the majority are
undocumented and this has been an Open
Secret for years now just watch this
interview with a farm owner from 2009
quickly take a turn how many guys do you
employ I have 22 full-time employees and
most of them Latino guys or are they
100 these guys citizens residents they
all are legal
how do you know that
cut the camera we talked off camera and
a few minutes later Myers allowed us to
resume the interview the legal
documentation that has been printed
they're they're illegal oh oh they are
are they I gotta say that is not a
particularly convincing bit of
misdirection there cover-wise it's about
as effective as a camouflage outfit that
just says not a guy on it the truth is
Farms depend heavily on foreign-born
workers to do harvesting and picking as
many crops are too delicate to be
mechanized that is why most fruits and
vegetables are still harvested by hand
and by and large American citizens have
shown very little interest in doing that
in fact when Washington State spent
thousands on an advertising campaign to
find U.S Farm Workers in 2021 it
resulted in one job referral and zero
hires but over the past decade and a
half changes in Immigration policy and
enforcement have made it much more
difficult for Farmers to find workers
forcing some extreme choices 6 000
people showed up on a Saturday for the
chance to pick some free veggies the
farmer whose family owns the field had
been Sleepless for days and getting ever
more agitated on Tick Tock I need this
video to go out and for people to see it
and understand the ramifications of
what's going on at the border and the
lack of Labor that we have in this
country agitated that he couldn't hire
enough people to pick the asparagus crop
some hundred and eighty thousand dollars
worth
so instead of throwing it away he gave
it away do you guys like eating this
between a child's natural hatred of
asparagus and their natural love of
disagreeing with siblings also I'm a
little embarrassed to admit I didn't
know that's what a field of asparagus
looks like you're telling me it doesn't
grow together in a nice little Bunch it
just sticks out of the ground
individually like a big field of body
hair tell me that doesn't look like you
put the jolly green Giants happy trail
under a microscope I'm mad
the point is without access to labor
crops just rot in the field it's
probably why Farm Workers were
categorized as essential by the
Department of Homeland Security during
the pandemic and yet while we claim
they're essential we sure don't treat
them like it Farm Workers are among our
lowest paid workers making on average in
the range of 20 to 25 000 a year and
they're often subjected to dangerous
environments join the California
wildfire season you may have seen videos
of Farm Workers toiling in the
foreground of a raging fire and even
when their workplace isn't actively
burning to the ground they will tell you
their work can sometimes feel pretty
dehumanizing one of the most difficult
things is just to go to a realization
how little you mean
to the people that that you are working
for
they don't officially start getting paid
until your first bucket is filled
if you fall behind you have to run to
try and catch up
a lot of people can't stand it because
it's so hot sometimes you could feel the
breeze from the pesticide they were
spraying over there
it felt good I thought he's pretty
brutal although appreciating the cooling
air from the pesticides is some
legendary glass half full thinking sure
it's hard work but the poison Breeze is
nice so it kind of balances out the way
our farm labor system works is deeply
exploited but the thing is that is very
much by Design so tonight let's talk
about Farm Workers the conditions they
face how we fail to protect them and
what we can do going forward and let's
start by acknowledging the history of
farm work in America has always been
rooted in exploitation from its origins
in slavery to its later Evolution into
sharecropping but what you might not
know is that during the New Deal as laws
were finally passed to establish some
Bedrock labor protections Farm Workers
were repeatedly and specifically
excluded from them so for instance the
1935 law which protected employees
rights to join unions explicitly stated
that the term employee shall not include
any individual employed as an
agricultural laborer and the 1938 law
which is a federal minimum wage and
overtime again carved out an exception
so those Provisions shall not apply to
anyone employed in agriculture which is
pretty insulting isn't it it's like
announcing your company's new
anti-sexual harassment policy but
clarifying that none of it protects Jeff
is exempt so slap his ass twist his nips
we don't care it is open season on Jeff
and make no mistake the reasons for that
were explicitly racist one
representative even warned joint debate
on the minimum wage bill that you cannot
put the Negro and the white man on the
same basis and get away with it that
representative it was actually Tucker
Carlson it turns out he's a Highlander
now since then the labor force has
changed Black America Americans left the
sharecropping system during the Great
Migration and Farmers increasingly came
to rely on laborers from Mexico and
other Central American nations and over
the years leaders like Cesar Chavez and
Dolores Huerta formed the United Farm
Workers and won some significant gains
the federal minimum wage was expanded to
include Farm Workers in 1978 and some
states do now provide at least some
access to overtime pay and collective
bargaining but the fact is Farm Workers
are still excluded from a lot of basic
labor protections including this major
one the child labor law in the U.S is
pretty good except when it comes to
Agriculture and then it has a big gay
people U.S law allows children to work
in agriculture at far younger ages for
unlimited hours outside of school in
much more dangerous conditions than any
others so a child can work perfectly
legally for any Farmer at age 12 that
child couldn't work serving the food
that he can work 10 12 18 hours picking
yeah and that is absurd and look I am
not saying that working in a restaurant
isn't tough anyone thinks otherwise
should be forced to serve an imperfect
omelet to James Corden but it's clearly
not the same thing is it and this
exception isn't just to let kids work on
their own family's Farms there are
higher children working in fields all
across America picking our food because
what most jobs are off limits to kids
under 14. agricultural employers may
even hire children younger than 12 to
work on small farms with written
parental consent and they should
probably go without saying but this work
can be dangerous for kids just listen to
this girl who started working in tobacco
Fields when she was only 12 describe her
first day on the job that felt really
lightheaded and dizzy and I wanted to go
get a cup of water and I could not see
to where the truck was that contained
the water and
I was looking for my mom and I couldn't
find my mom
eventually I just fell you don't really
think about a childhood like I've never
really thought that a child is really
supposed to at 12 year olds is supposed
to have fun exactly I always thought
that you were supposed to work that is
terrible although while a 12 year olds
under no circumstance it should be
fainting in a field I will say it is a
bit of a stretch to say that a 12 year
old is supposed to have fun because
fundamentally they are still 12. this is
just around the corner for me you are a
hormonal ticking time bomb at that age
honestly the closest thing to fund that
is available to you at 12 is going to
the mall by yourself for the first time
to just kind of walk around I guess
since you don't really have any money
except for like a smoothie or something
if you want to get a smoothie or
whatever
the lack of
applying to Farm Workers has left them
facing truly dangerous conditions
agricultural workers suffer fatal
on-the-job injuries at a rate far higher
than police officers and more than twice
the rate of construction workers which
is wild because it's one thing to look
up at a tall building and shutter
thinking about the physical risk it must
have taken to put a pane of glass up
that high but it feels ridiculous to
feel the same way about a beet and goat
cheese salad
Farm Workers face exposure to extreme
heat dangerous Machinery unsafe air
quality and impromptu pesticide showers
and some Farm owners can be abusive
employers just take this story from a
few years ago
it's quiet but cloudy at EDS Sean Barn
Orchard today hello
but not on this day apart
it was hot it's a tower
the voice on tape Travis schoenborn the
son of farm owners David and Valerie
schoenborn he was angry at one of the
workers and let it be known in front of
others tell him
well he still can
the other at all holy that was
about 95 bleeps and Trust local news to
always find a diplomatic way to describe
things he was angry and let it be known
in front of others sure that's not
technically untrue but I'd have gone
with the more accurate description he
lost his at an apple farm a
farmer remembered that his parents owned
and they had a truly special response
when confronted with that video they
blame the migrant worker alleged victim
in this case and accuse him of
threatening Valerie and being obscene
what did he do to threaten you he called
me a name in Spanish I'm not repeating
it there was no outright apology instead
this first of all they weren't black
they were Mexicans
so I don't know why he called them the
n-word I just want to give you a chance
to be to be clear and respond yeah you
hear him referring to people as
Nick
but I know
okay okay okay here's the thing I mean
well clearly there are 9 000 things
there but here is just one of them I bet
you heard her say they were Mexicans so
I'm not sure why he called them the
n-word and thought wow that is the
wildest anybody in this marriage is
going to say in the next 15 seconds and
then you were dead wrong what's I just
want to point out the inconsistency
between having a problem with saying a
vague unknown word in Spanish and having
no problem at all saying an extremely
specific one in English I won't repeat
this Spanish word because it's offensive
but if you talk to my husband he'll say
the N word in about Force seconds anyway
I raised my son better than to use slurs
incorrectly
now in that particular case a worker
caught that tirade on video and gave it
to migrant legal aid and the son later
pled guilty to of all things disturbing
the peace but even that pathetic level
of accountability is extremely rare and
look clearly not all farmers are abusive
employers but to the extent that any
want to be that can be shockingly little
to stop them because even when labor
laws do apply to agricultural workers
There is almost no way to enforce them
take California the most productive
agricultural state in the nation the
agency responsible for monitoring
workplace safety there is so
understaffed that it currently has
roughly one field inspector available
for every 90 000 workers with only a
handful of those inspectors speaking any
language other than English and even
when there are consequences they can be
laughable after two Farm Workers in
Idaho drowned in pits of cow manure at
Dairy operations OSHA in post finds of
just five thousand dollars for each of
the men's debts which is nothing if an
employee drowned in the universally
agreed upon worst thing to drown in that
should cost their employer a lot more
than a fifth of a Hyundai Sonata and
that's not even getting into the fact
that some Farms limit their liability by
using so-called Farm labor contractors
who hire workers and then contract them
out and who've been found to be the
worst violators of federal employment
law in agriculture some of them have
confiscated workers passport charge them
if they wanted to quit their jobs or
threaten them with deportation so at
every turn this is an environment where
vulnerable workers can understandably
feel reluctant to come forward take
sexual harassment and assault which Farm
Workers say is a big problem and yet
just watch how this head of a farm
owners trade group responds when asked
about it
you know Dolores Huerta you know she had
yes okay can I read you something she
said oh please I'd like to hear
her comment okay she says that this
sexual harassment that we're talking
about is an epidemic in the fields
doloreswerter bring me those cases go
have your ufw go uh go pick at the
grower if all these cases have been
going on
if our Growers know there's a problem
we're going to deal with it why didn't
you go to the grower
and tell me that because well we were
feared for their jobs and their lives no
that's a poor excuse
yeah is it though is it because I've got
to say I can believe that people aren't
bringing harassment cases to Growers if
they're acting anything like he just did
after all merely hearing the name
Dolores Huerta sent him into a visible
rage so I have to imagine that off
camera he's even more of a teddy bear
and at this point you might be thinking
well perhaps one way to help workers
would be to remove their fear of
deportation and create a system where
they can come into this country legally
well we actually did that but
unfortunately the way we did it left
massive gaps for Bad actors to operate
in back in 1986 we created what's known
as the h2a Visa program it allows
migrant workers to legally enter the
country temporarily for agricultural
work for years employers showed away
from using it because it was cheaper and
easier to Simply hire undocumented
workers but as it's become harder to
find them the use of h2a has been ramped
up considerably in fact the number of
h2a positions has increased more than
seven fold in the past 17 years
basically the programs been around since
the 80s was on the back burner until a
few years ago and now it's extremely
popular think of it as the Kieran Culkin
of the Agricultural world
in principle people h2a does sound good
and more Farm Workers get temporary
legal status which you would assume
would make them feel safer but sadly
that just hasn't been the case for one
thing like many work visas these are
tied to your employer so if you lose
your job you also lose your right to be
in the country causing a massive power
imbalance and given that imbalance it is
no surprise that many employers feel
comfortable skirting the protections
that workers are supposed to receive for
instance under the law employers must
provide housing for their h2a workers
but in practice the conditions can be
far below what the program requires as
this man quickly found out
the house where we lived where Manuel
brought us to was very old it had
spiders cockroaches and the bathrooms
didn't work the house was gross it was
very dirty you could clearly tell that
the house was abandoned for a long time
and Manuel brought us there the house
didn't have heat and the temperature hit
6 degrees Celsius and four of my
co-workers and I had to sleep outside we
felt like we were on the border of death
that is horrific no one would see that
and say that is a good place for people
to live they maybe say that's a nice
spot for ghosts to throw up but that's
it and that's not a one-off a DOL
investigation a few years back found
that one labor contractor house h2a
workers in an old County Jail that have
recently served to the community's
Halloween haunted house this is the
kitchen which you can see still had fake
blood on the refrigerators and the floor
and workers clearly shouldn't be forced
to sleep around a bunch of spooky
decorations even people who work at
Spirit Halloween don't sleep in the
store except of course for Dennis but
he's made it very clear that that is a
sex thing
but poor living accommodations are just
the tip of the iceberg here in 2021 the
doj launched a massive indictment
involving the treatment of H2O workers
on Georgia farms and the details are
appalling prosecutors calling it modern
day slavery in the fields of Southern
Georgia years worth of damning horrific
allegations victims allegedly forced to
live in cramped dirty trailers with raw
sewage leaking into the trailers
threatened them with deportation and
detained them in a Work Camp surrounded
by an electric fence and in 2018 30
individuals allegedly sold to another
man in Indiana for twenty one thousand
four hundred and eighty one dollars
wow you know at times some people can be
quick to play the this is slavery card
whether you're a teenager asked to mow
the lawn or an office worker who has to
come in on Sunday but as frustrating as
those situations can be neither involves
being sold in bulk to a man in Indiana
because that is actual slavery
this case is ongoing but the indictment
asserts that this was a massive
operation we sought visas for over 71
000 foreign workers to harvest onions
and other crops and the government says
that at least two died as a result of
the workplace conditions there and while
I'm glad that action was eventually
taken I will say for a list of charges
this Sinister the name they chose could
have used some work a new 54-page
indictment by the U.S Department of
Justice charging 24 individuals is part
of what it calls operation blooming
onion
personal Outback Steakhouse who saw
blooming onion trending on Twitter and
thought their job got easier for two
seconds before realizing that actually
just got a lot harder
and at this point I've told you about
everything from child labor to workers
drowning in manure to this sale of human
beings so you're hopefully wondering how
do we fix this well Farm Workers have
been organizing to address some of these
issues for years now take what happened
in Immokalee Florida as recently as a
decade ago the Tomato Fields there were
being called Ground Zero for modern day
slavery but a group called The Coalition
of Immokalee workers launched a campaign
to improve conditions pressuring not
just Farmers but the big name businesses
that relied on their produce in 2005
Taco Bell became the first big buyer to
sign on to the ciw's fair food program
buyers agree to pay an extra penny per
pound for tomato money that goes to
workers and buyers only do business with
participating Florida Farmers more than
a dozen restaurant chains and retailers
have signed on including McDonald's
chipotle Trader Joe's and last year
Walmart which sells 20 percent of
America's tomatoes
wow those are some massive brands that
you can now surprisingly feel kind of
okay about in this one very narrow way
is Walmart a good company overall it's
not up for me to say but let's say no
it's absolutely terrible but is it a
good company regarding the tomatoes it
sells from Florida specifically sure on
that one issue they have my full Florida
tomato specific support
which is frankly more than I can say for
Wendy's Kroger and publics who amazingly
have yet to sign on so them
under the fair food program
signatories agreed to purchase only from
Growers who implemented a human
rights-based code of conduct on their
Farms it also covers a 24 7 complaint
line for workers and perhaps most
importantly an independent regulatory
body that conducts audits in which they
interview at least half the workforce
and it's been a success the vast
majority of tomato Harvesters in Florida
have joined the program raising wages
for tens of thousands of workers and the
program is now expanding into other
crops in other states but it clearly
shouldn't just be on Farm Workers to
fight for a decent life we need to make
sure that they are at least protected by
the same labor laws that the rest of us
enjoy and make sure that those laws are
actually enforced and I would argue that
we also need to retool the h2a program
and ensure that it's participants and
ideally all Farm Workers have a
potential path to citizenship because
after working so hard to feed this
country frankly they deserve one after
all you made me a citizen and I haven't
fed you once I know I know that you
think I have but that's Jamie Oliver and
we are different people
look Farm Workers provide this country
with our most basic necessity and in
return We act like they either don't
matter or don't exist the message that
we have sent to them has consistently
been you don't count until we fix our
broken system the very least that we can
do is fix our Farming Simulator game so
that everyone is forced to have a much
more accurate sense of what the people
who grow their food are actually up
against
welcome to the new Farming Simulator
2023 all your favorite features are back
beautiful Vistas tough working tractors
and of course animal husbandry
but this year we're also expanding to
include the parts of farming most people
don't like to think about hired Farm
Workers we're bringing Cutting Edge
graphics and gameplay to the most
ignored aspect of Agriculture you'll be
able to choose between hiring
undocumented workers with no protections
against abuse or the a legal version of
that you can customize their clothes
their hair even choose from a surprising
range of Ages from older to younger to
Dear God how on Earth is this legal
we've also got a brand new assortment of
maps from Midwestern fields to vast
asparagus taints to literally the middle
of a raging wildfire and if your workers
need a pet talk you can help them out
with our new motivational mini game
warm up
your odds of getting caught are
practically zero oh you can also
use our new housing tool to design h2a
compliant-ish housing for your workers
the less you spend the more you save and
all of this is to put food on the table
of people who will never once think
about how it got there just remember the
real secret to mastering farming is
being the master of other people
wait not that
I guess kind of that Farming Simulator
rated not okay for anyone